mesdames messieurs bon dimanche le
président américain Joe Biden débarque
au Canada ce jeudi une première visite
depuis son arrivée à la Maison Blanche
un voyage retardé de deux ans en raison
de la pandémie c'est juste un Trudeau a
plus d'atomes crochus avec le président
actuel qu'avec son prédécesseur la
relation n'est pas sans irritant entre
autres en matière d'immigration
d'économie et de sécurité des dossiers
sensibles la visite de deux jours
permettra-t-elle de faire des progrès
Queen ambassadrice du Canada Washington
bonjour merci d'être avec nous c'est un
plaisir vous êtes ici pour la semaine
évidemment vous allez vous allez être là
pendant la visite du président américain
à quoi vous attendez-vous de cette
visite
nous attendons que ils mettent leur
phase surtout sur les questions
bilatérales les questions entre le
Canada et les États-Unis bien sûr ils
vont parler des enjeux internationaux
mais surtout j'espère qu'on va sortir de
ces réunions là avec une avoir eu une
grande conversation sur comment le
Canada et les États-Unis travaillent
ensemble un peu pour
soutenir les uns les autres et
travailler ensemble à l'international
quels sont les quels sont les enjeux
bilatéraux sur lesquels le Canada les
États-Unis doivent travailler
présentement je crois qu'on doit
travailler sur les
changements qui se passent dans notre
économie suite à ce que nous avons
appris avec la pandémie covid et avec
les bouleversements qu'on a eu dans
l'économie globale avec l'invasion de la
Russie en Ukraine c'est-à-dire nous
avons des chaînes d'approvisionnement
qui sont
perturber nous avons des manques de
produits stratégiques des certaines
minéraux certaines produits qu'il faut
pour qu'ils sont surtout
manufacturiers en Chine et ailleurs
alors nous essayons de réunir nos pays
pour qu'on se soutient les uns les
autres et on se soutient entre les
Alliés vous avez parlé d'économies j'ai
pas parlé d'immigration le Canada veut
beaucoup parler d'immigration avec la
Maison Blanche ça fait partie des
éléments qui seront sur la table
l'immigration
irrégulière
c'est certain ça va être sur l'agenda
la migration irrégulière c'est un crise
aux États-Unis aussi l'année dernière
ils ont eu deux millions de migrants qui
ont traversé leur frontières au sud
alors la conversation que nous allons
avoir et que nous avons déjà mais qui va
continuer bien sûr entre nos chefs
d'État c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
l'atmosphère comment est-ce que nous
pouvons bien sûr donner soutien à ces
personnes qui sont en crise mais aussi
d'une façon qui fait une gestion
propre et équitable et prévisible à nos
frontières leurs frontières et le notre
bien sûr vous vous l'avez vous avez
souligné l'importance de ce problème là
pour les Américains du côté sud on a
l'impression que Monsieur Biden la
Maison Blanche se soucie peu de la
préoccupation du côté Nord alors que
c'est énorme de ce côté-ci est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir un mouvement de ce côté-là
ce qui a des chances que ça bouge
premièrement ce n'est pas qui ne se
soucie pas de du frontière du Nord il et
ça je peux le dire vrai très franchement
l'administration Biden
s'intéresse à tout ce qui nous intéresse
c'est à dire si c'est important pour le
Canada ils vont nous écouter ils vont
essayer de de trouver une solution avec
nous des fois ça marche des fois ça
prend du temps des fois il faut trouver
des compromis mais ils sont toujours à
l'écoute et ça il faut il faut le dire
ceci dit c'est une problème qui est plus
large que notre frontière et
ça implique vraiment une difficulté à la
source de cette immigration alors je
crois comme je vous ai dit je crois que
c'est certain qu'ils vont en parler les
deux chefs d'État nous en parle beaucoup
le ministre à Washington la semaine
dernière
c'est moins sûr c'est ça il va
je sais pas c'est conversations
continuent j'espère que ils ont de la
bonne volonté ça prend du temps le
Canada les voix s'élèvent pour fermer le
chemin Roxane modifier l'entente sur les
tiers pays sûr est-ce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui est réalisable durant
la visite de Monsieur binden est-ce
qu'on peut faire des mouvements de ce
côté là je crois que c'est vraiment
c'est plutôt une grande conversation
dans le contexte tout le migration qui
se passe parlons d'économie
comment on peut faire Ottawa pour tenter
de s'isoler des impacts de la loi
américaine sur la sur la réduction de
l'inflation
prévu comme une mesure très
protectionniste à certains égards
ils désignaient ils économistes nous
disent c'est difficile de compétitionner
contre ce genre de mesure là qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire de ce côté-ci de la
frontière pour tenter de prévenir ou
prévoir l'impact de tout ça et moi j'ai
entendu aussi ces économistes et il m'en
parle beaucoup mais moi ce que je vois
c'est ça je vois une loi qui a été
promulguée par les Américains qui suit
les mêmes politiques que le Canada
depuis un certain moment c'est à dire
nous nous avons une agenda de
électrification de notre système de
transport de batterie de change de
transition
vers les sources d'énergie plus propre
depuis plusieurs années les américains
ils commencent le chemin c'est vrai
qu'il commence d'une façon très fort
mais il commence alors
premièrement dans cette loi il y a tout
un système tout une catégorie de
d'investissement sur les batteries sur
les minéraux critiques sur les véhicules
électriques qui reconnaît l'intégration
Canada Amérique et Mexique ça c'est une
avantage énorme pour nous pour nos
minéraux critiques pour notre écosystème
de batterie et bien sûr pour notre
secteur automobile ça nous donne une
avantage que aucune autre
pays à vis-à-vis l'énorme marché
américain pour ce qui est de d'autres
investissements qui font dans cette
loi-là je crois que ce qui est important
de savoir c'est que nous aussi nous nous
faisons nos propres investissements nous
faisons nos investissements pour
atterrir ces industries au Canada et ça
ça commence à marcher pas le pouvoir de
frappe des États-Unis quand vient le
temps les subventions qui sont offertes
pour ce genre d'investissement là aux
États-Unis sont dit majorément plus
élevés que ce que l'on peut offrir au
Canada oui mais ils sont 10 fois plus
grands que nous aussi c'est à dire il
faut voir ça il faut faire la traduction
entre la taille de leur pays de leur
économie de consommateur et le nôtre
nous avons d'autres propositions à
mettre sur la table pour être compétitif
nous avons bien sûr les minéraux
primaires nous avons une expérience là
dedans depuis longtemps et nous avons
des mains d'oeuvre qui est vraiment très
expérimentés et je dirais une autre
chose et ça c'est vraiment très
important à savoir c'est que la demande
pour ces produits ces produits de
d'électricité verte de d'énergie verte
il y a beaucoup plus de demandes qu'il y
a de production en ce moment alors c'est
pas une question de compétition c'est
pas comme on dit en anglais yeux ça me
game un day vainqueur était perdants
c'est il faut que tout le monde fasse
autant qu'ils puissent aussi vite que
possible et là c'est un message qu'on
donne aux Américains nous allons
continuer à donner la semaine prochaine
canadienne une préoccupation américaine
aussi ce que l'on ce que l'on comprend
ce que l'on entend c'est que les
Américains voudraient bien que le Canada
s'implique de façon plus directe sur le
terrain ça va faire partie de la
conversation ça nous bien sûr de l'Haïti
nous avons nous avons les mêmes
objectifs que les Américains en Haïti
c'est-à-dire de trouver une façon de
stabiliser la situation de
d'assurer la sécurité des Haïtiens nous
avons fait plusieurs choses déjà avec
les sanctions
[Musique]
l'entraînement du de la police nationale
parce que c'est ça que les Haïtiens
demandent alors c'est ça qu'on va
essayer de faire les sanctions le Canada
Italie de façon beaucoup plus agressive
que les Américains est-ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'il y a moyen de convaincre les
États-Unis d'avancer un peu plus loin
dans le régime de sanctions mais on en
parle beaucoup mais c'est vraiment une
question pour les Américains on aimerait
bien que qu'il y ait autant peu possible
des sanctions qui viennent de partout
les Américains des yeux européens des
pays dans les régions là où l'argent où
on trouve l'argent qui finance c'est
c'est gagne Haïti il faut qu'on atteint
cet argent
au Canada on en parle beaucoup ici et
qu'on en parle moins aux États-Unis
est-ce que c'est moins important pour
les Américains ou est-ce que la
perception est différente de votre de
votre point de vue à Washington je peux
vous dire avant de venir ici tout le
monde à washingtaine me parle de cette
visite tout le monde alors non je crois
que ils ont ils ont beaucoup de sujets à
toujours aux États-Unis mais vis-à-vis
le Canada ils sont ils ont très
intéressés par cette visite personnelle
ambassadrice du Canada Washington merci
infiniment d'avoir été des nôtres un
plaisir merci